I got some good news and I got some bad
news uh give me the bad news or the bad
news first first let's start with that
well so I bought a Prius as you know I
retrieved it right
oh well hold on let's listen to know
that you bought a Prius you lent it to a
guy you read about that usually doesn't
wear a shirt and didn't have a car at 40
years old and he's like you know I'm
gonna leave it in the shady neighborhood
with the keys in it yeah well I go
inside and take care of some business
and car gets stolen
bye-bye okay carry on yes by a crackhead
and the reason I know it's a crackhead
is because I found crack pipes under the
seat okay okay that's fine
cleaned it out I guess somewhere along
the line it didn't get locked on the
street of Venice and
well homeless man took a little
nappy-poo and is living it oh dude [ __ ]
in it nobody just took a little
nappy-poo nothing wrong with nothing
wrong with that Prius that's true
the problem is when you get into it I
drove it here I've had to transport them
the dogs exact oh I got it back oh you
didn't know I got it back no the police
god bless God bless the LAPD I talked to
a cop this pressing issues weren't well
I know stupid pretty I talk to a cop and
I and he said we'll get it back
and I said you'll get the car back how
and he goes if they didn't goes plate it
or bring it to a chop shop we'll get it
back flying down the street and they
found it in and in that day and because
apparently which I didn't know they run
plates oh yeah what so so they found
that wrong Hey found a runaway a good
news bad news crack pipes and a bum
literally [ __ ] all over I told you this
probably last podcast but I want to give
a quick shout out everybody I spoke to
in the police department everybody I
spokes probably 10 founder of ten people
including the detective all said this
this is frozen they go we're really
sorry this happened to you we hope you
have a better day there's a little thing
made a difference made a difference I
appreciate their professionalism so I
get it back
cost me there's money it'd be better if
they didn't return what get final
insurance probably I bring it back to
Toyota they got to do some stuff to it
yeah clean it out I play house
definitely ask Ovid and Czar's whatever
all that all bums have all that I knows
well there is a homeless man sleeping in
my car in the backseat yeah pretty comfy
comfy and I'm a compassionate man
I'm Manuel no I said hey but I can't use
this as at home cuz some car what do you
say and he his eyebrows were I've seen
him before
they are so long his fingernails his
eyebrows nose eyebrows are bushy beyond
bushy bring up Brezhnev
bring up Li annoyed Brezhnev hold on
it's me the big furry so they say hey
your cars here you go to pick it up the
bums in there sleeping yeah and they say
here your cars on 9th and rows yeah now
see those eyebrows right there those
look like Kylie Jenner's eyebrows
compared to this guy's out there two
caterpillars yeah nothing yeah so yeah
so did Ellie
Kelly you go hey dude three cars off
ninth ninth and Rose go pick it up
yourself
no they tow it they tell it and how's
the bump sleeping oh no no this was
after I got it back this i I've had it
back now I've had my car back for a
while okay so so it was out parked in
front of my house online in Venice
unlocked and as you know Venice has a
bit of a homeless problem California
does yeah
so he was in the car he looked at me and
he goes my my name is Billy and I said
well I'd be let's do yeah but I can't
have you stay or are you over 40
here's your name Robert my name's Robert
we're not calling you Bill anymore at
least cute is no Bobby Robert D right
but he's older older man and I believe
not a drug addict he's a straight-up
wino a straight-up booze Lacy's wine yes
now now a defier gin it when I tell you
that it smelled like a nope and I'm all
due respect you just haven't had a
chance to shower but it smelled like an
open grave and I had to drive here and
with the windows open oh it's a lot e
order an oil sucked into that
unbelievable and it's not leather to
Prius there's no leather it's it's knit
cloth see it's it's it's actually um
leather but that the faux like yeah the
foam attic leather we can sweat it down
yeah rector so athletic look there you
go yeah let it show his body odor just
soak this okay into that that's not easy
to get rid of now did you shoot him the
head or just straight in the face I slew
him I slowed my Castro I corroded him I
I said Shh I took some piano wire I said
Shh
you had better luck next next life and
that's the goodness that's the good okay
it's been laid to rest no the good news
is you pronounced miss so god bless him
god bless him either coat your car's
Kovac I gave him some water I gave him
some mortar because you haven't got you
got any water I go I'll get you some
water I got him some water I'm a nice
guy
well no if you're a nice your game wine
I'm sorry Yuri give him some wine tell
you this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]